hi everyone welcome back to another
episode of big moon it's actually a
bonus episode some extra moods for you
today is our first time doing this it's
gonna be a whole new segment where we
answer your questions that you asked us
like you're part of our chat I said
access but you asked us on Instagram so
we put some feelers out there and we
said what have you always wanted to ask
us questions for advice or anything and
we decided let's do that so we can reach
or we can hang out with you guys it's
like we're hanging out with you guys at
home take their part of our text change
mm-hmm but the thing is we don't have a
name for this segment yet so it's a
little Q&A segment we'll get ya mood
yeah put some ideas down there for us
maybe someone will come up with
something good because you shot it for
that but also if you want your questions
to be answered in the future make sure
you're following us on Instagram and we
will be putting the feelers out in the
stories you know the story question
responses so if you want to do that just
follow us on Instagram and wait for the
next one
mood girls we're gonna keep doing it so
so we can keep it anonymous too if you
prompt us now I pulled a bunch of
questions last night we got so many
thanks guys yeah so we're gonna go
through as many as we possibly could all
right so let's start with something
maybe like a little a little a little
bit lighter okay okay ready
all right so this one I thought was
really cute this is from Aisha Manila
she says how to flirt but me be
mysterious at the same time oh I don't
like something about you I'm not gonna
tell you what it is I don't flirt and
you almost need to be Oh like overt with
guys I don't know if there's just the
guys that I've been around but sometimes
I hella think I'm flirting and they did
not pick that up at all and then
sometimes I'm just like ballbusting and
just being like my normal self and they
totally think I'm flirting with them
yeah so I don't know there might be like
a balance of showing kind of a green
light without giving away too much so
the way I if I was gonna tell her like
oh there's this cute guy she likes the
way I would tell her to do it it's just
like there's little signs of acceptance
to a guy so it's like body language like
if me and Nikki are on a date and this
is our first time and maybe we're
sitting at the bar at a restaurant and
then so flirting with him it would be
kind of like I would definitely be a
little bit more body language showed but
also you don't want to overdo it which
is why she said mysterious right so like
you'll just do subtle things like
holding eye contact a little bit longer
I think it's more about maybe body
language just to show flirtiness or
acceptance or like how would you want
someone to like approach you physically
to show that you're interested without
actually saying with words that you're
interested or you know like being
overtly sexual or something like that
kinda takes away the mystery but if it's
just like physically facially or you'll
laugh at their jokes or you'll shows
little signs of acceptance I feel like
that's a good way to flirt without yeah
without really showing your cards you
know be like oh my god I really like you
yeah
all right don't over divulge don't go
into your childhood and everything on
the first date that will scare people
away leave that as a mystery you show
them the crazy after trap just throw it
all to the wall literally just like word
vomit
you know what I'll hold back from doing
that be a good listener like right it's
listening here like asking them
questions making them feel important I
don't know stuff you notice if they're
even asking you questions in the first
place because some guys are like oh me
me me me me me me me me and they just
never ask me yeah it's even worth
flirting with or you know exactly so you
need to gauge while you're potentially
flirting my thing is I don't kiss them
for the longest time like they'll try to
kiss me I'm like goodnight and that's
the longest time I kiss on a first date
cuz I'm like where's the second date and
the only way I'm gonna find out is if I
kiss you test the merchandise yeah
that's a make or break I feel like a
fourth or fifth date
so much wasted time know that it went
really well and I totally want to see
you again but I'm not gonna give you
like a kiss just like that way because
I'm annoying I don't know like I just I
like to I like make them your precious
or GM but also I feel like it's more
about me it's like do I want this or not
oh I see and if I don't want that kiss
if I kiss him and I'm like I would not I
would be so pissed if I wasted five
dates what if you're on a date and you
already know you don't want to kiss them
like definitely yeah yeah okay his
conversation is good he's handsome he's
easy to talk to you he hasn't done
anything rude or red-flag II so far I
might consider putting his penis in my
vagina
but first yes the past the makeup yes
I'm a Jess and so last of the criteria
before opening the gates yes otherwise I
feel like I'm just dragging him out to
dinner five times and taking five times
worth of his money and I want to know
right now if it's good or not I like to
I like to make him work for it so then
like I give him a kiss on the cheek
maybe like the second or third date and
they're like oh my god is mysterious I
guess that's a lot more mysterious yeah
it just depends on what what you're
going for a girl okay I mean I was never
in that dating world that's why it like
now like you're dating yeah well I'm
just like girl what's that like I mean I
wouldn't call myself an expert in
anything I'm just telling you what I
would do and you have to decide would
you want my life or not I sure never
take advice from someone yeah don't want
their life only take advice from someone
you want to be like okay so next
question is from so don't take any of
our advice shouldn't take any of our
entertainment but we don't want to be
like this next question is from Lewis
says ho excuse me thank you how is that
a Chinese name or he asks what's the
first thing a woman notices on a man
like physically
Oh anything really like as very per
woman emotionally yeah
hey like personality-wise lice
immediately low voice okay okay for me
it's like how his presence is I think
like around me like how does he conduct
himself like you can feel energy yeah
exactly the energy and without even like
talking to the person I could already
sense like what kind of person that
they'll have like what the personality
based off of their energy and the way
they carry themselves so let's say like
this is like the first date alright mmm
what do you guys kind of notice on the
first date personally for me how they
can realign date well when you're
swiping on dating out yeah and it feels
like a blind I guess so because you're
like well I think I know what he looks
like oftentimes people look a little bit
different from each other 7.5 10 years
yeah so that's why I say the very first
thing I notice is height I'm like is he
tall or not and then I start going down
all this other [ __ ] yeah for me I notice
how they treat the waitstaff like if
you're absolutely on I'm not about it at
all or if they're funny I like funny
dudes yeah yes
the first thing no no no not that you're
right yeah I think um how they dress
like yes yeah before it didn't I didn't
really care much but now as you reach
like a older age you're like absolutely
you know themselves yeah for me with
shoes like in high school I write like
that whenever I liked a guy and stuff I
would see what kind of shoes you're
wearing or how like he maintained his
shoes that to me was it was shoes for me
and lips and jaw line like dude lips for
sure I I know I don't have very big lips
cuz I'm a standard white girl I have
small standard white girl a lips of me
but when I see a guy with big lips I'm
like he's getting a chance for sure
because I think it started with Tom
Hardy my obsession with Tom Hardy's got
those big ol dick sucking lips
wanted to quit sucking lips I like how a
guy smells - yeah yeah it was a big I
mean all this clearly like superficial
things are probably what we noticed
first and then when we start talking
there's other things like how they carry
themselves for sure that's like a it's
like a feeling like you can see when
they walk through the door like how they
carry themselves and then for me I said
voice because like people that have a
grounded voice grounded energy you can
tell they're really listening and stuff
they have a different tone to their
voice then someone that's like forward
presenting and like they're like alright
so what do you like it's very like I
feel that for sure it definitely throws
me up because it's they're being fake
and they're like IDing something so that
the lower their voice goes the more
grounded the more I feel like I can
trust them right yeah I can't date a
high voice yeah come down here and while
you're down here you're down there
smelling good is so you have a just safe
bet at smelling good start with your
deodorant
that's right native guys guys and girls
and we actually have two scents with
this right now lavender and Rose this is
probably more of a feminine scent of a
sea salt and cedar that's cuter this
Rose one smells it reminds me of a spa
that one definitely smells more manly
the cedar I think adds to that he's a
good man smell anyways this is
formulated without aluminum parabens or
talc it's also vegan and never tested on
animals it's made with ingredients
you've actually heard of like coconut
oil and shea butter and so making the
switch to aluminum free deodorant does
not mean you have to sacrifice on
performance it will keep you smelling
and feeling fresh all day long and they
have over 10 cents there's definitely a
scent you're gonna find in that you like
Ivan disliked any of the sounds like
every single one they sent us has been
great sent us none of that no there's a
variety of options for men women and
teens they also offer an unscented
option and a baking-soda free formula if
you are sensitive there's no there's no
risk to try free shipping on every order
and offers and they offer a 30-day free
return or exchange in the USA if you're
still not convinced check out they're
over nine thousand five star reviews I
actually I feel like the texture on this
is really good and it just smells so
good and it feels nice and smooth I love
the way it feels
for 20% off your first purchase visit
native deodorant calm and use promo code
big mood during checkout again that's
for 20% off your first purchase visit
native deodorant calm and use promo code
big mood during checkout that was
magnificent yes you smell good on the
outside but do you feel good on the
inside no really not good
III always look good on the inside it's
just black tar but not any more because
I've been using care of which is a
vitamin supplement branagh vitamins
that's is a relevant brand that makes it
easy to maintain your health goals with
a customized vitamin plan that helps you
feel your best today and supports you
long-term I have never taken care of my
insides but now I started because of
care of its hassle-free vitamins and
supplements delivered to you it makes
taking your vitamins and supporting your
health goals attainable the convenient
daily packs are perfect for on-the-go
lifestyles just throw one in your purse
or gym bag and you're on your way no I
love these vitamins because like
initially they make you take a quiz and
then you get to find out like what is it
that you're concerned about with your
insides like what do you want to take
care of that black tar darkness more
like tiredness that's like maybe it's
more vitamin D because you never go
outside Jena cheeto puffs yeah
that's all my quiz they're like oh god
we need to send her everything so I
personally go for something that helps
get my energy in the morning because I
have none but on the opposite end also
somebody helps me sleep at night and
also like beauty sells like collagen
pills and stuff like that because I am
vain okay you know I do nothing to take
care of it yeah I really like using
their little the powder it's like a
little bit of powder and now you like
the energy one because it gives like a
nice little like clean boost but it
tastes really good just dissolve it in
your tongue you're good to go
and it comes in like a cute package
where you just pull a packet out every
day it's cool it makes me feel like I'm
doing something every day being healthy
mm-hmm for 50% off your first care of
order go to take care up calm and enter
big mood 50 mm-hmm again that's 50% off
your first care of order go to take care
of calm and answer big mood 50 take care
of your insides don't don't be like me
so let's get a little bit more serious
okay I'm ready um I feel like this
question can help everyone in a
relationship the question is from the
realest Jay Derulo's the realest how do
you argue fairly with your partner I
have a hard time reaching a middle
ground
listen whoo-hoo that's hard you need to
listen I think that you need to I think
the number one people think people
struggle with is feeling like their
partners their enemy in that moment yeah
and wanting to win rather than thinking
of your partner as being on the same
team as you and wanting to achieve a
common goal right and so when you're
listening to what's upsetting them you
can understand and then and then make
your point based on like what is
upsetting them bit without invalidating
that right right to validate what
they're upset about and then be like
okay I can see why you're upset
and here is my side you know and see
what we learned in in therapy like when
Casey and I were going to like marriage
counseling they taught us how to
communicate with one another because we
were we were trying to understand each
other but we weren't using language that
the other person is able to receive so
then like the first like the
I don't like the first step like is what
you're saying which is you need to hear
the other person out once you're hearing
them you need to you need to say what it
is that you heard like how you
understood it in your what it is in your
own words exactly so you're like okay I
hear that you're saying this and this is
how you felt and this is what happened
and like you're you're giving them their
own ideas back like they're the run down
from how you understood it and you can
make sure it's correct - exactly yeah
that's really what it is first it's like
cool I understood your side so we got it
we got it then you go into well this is
my perspective on it I felt this way and
this is how like you know you I felt
this way about the situation whatever it
is and once you give your input out then
the other person has to do the same
thing back and like okay what I
understood was this and this and this
and then here's my perspective and
that's like the the therapy way of
communicating if you really can't even
reach because we were at that point
where it's like I we are trying so hard
to understand each other but no matter
what we say or how we say it and that
moment it really felt like we're just
speaking two completely different
languages and this is just getting worse
so you're fighting just for yourself not
for the relationship exactly so then at
that point once you're able to
understand just like what Nikki was
saying is like spot-on because once
you're able to understand where the
issues are coming from from the other
side and then the other side heard where
you were coming from from your side
you're able to see the situation clearly
like a clear like Ariel like bird's-eye
view of the of the problem and so once
you see that problem you're able to
attack it as a team instead of like
being enemies about it and like
understanding like okay then how do we
fix this or like what is the possible
solution and because your emotions just
want to be understood like your your
logic is like separate so like if your
emotions don't feel hurt or understood
then you can't even get to the lock and
that's what you were saying about the
validating yeah exactly it it really is
totally yeah I there is this example
that I heard and it's just about it's
kind of that thing about like separating
yourself from the situation it was this
one girl on a youtube channel I forgot
her name but she was she made this
example she said consider yourself to be
like a lab assistant or a lab researcher
and not to be the mouse in the maze so
it's kind of like whenever you get so
you're like so deep entrenched in
whatever it is that's driving you [ __ ]
crazy you're kind of like this mouse
that's like going through the maze and
it can't figure out how to get out like
you can't figure out how to get out this
argument right it's like you got to
consider to put the scientist jacket on
and say okay how do I remove myself from
this argument and literally just write
it out as a statement how would I write
this out on a research paper my
girlfriend doesn't like that I do this
or let you know it's just like about
separating your your emotions from it so
I don't know if anyone can can relate to
the idea of like get out of the maze as
the rat put on the lab coat and see
yourself as like above this problem you
know it also helps to approach the
conversation in a same team aspect is
another thing that we learned in therapy
which is not to use the word you yeah
you're referring to what how like
whatever it is like if me and Jess got
an argument I will I won't have to if
I'm saying things like well you did this
and you did this and I got pissed off
because you whatever it is I still you
have to do I statements where it's like
well I felt hurt when like there's
always happen it helps so much because
then it does remove the ego actually if
it was not attacking the other person so
then they don't feel like they have to
defend themselves because they're not
getting it yeah you show vulnerability
yourself to because you're like it hurts
me because otherwise when you're arguing
you're just like well you're a piece of
[ __ ]
you're that but like if you show them
I'm I'm hurting from this or it like it
crushed me when you said that or I mean
obviously you saying that sounds a
little fight words too but it's like it
crushed me when this happened it made me
feel low so it's like you just have to
understand why they feel like why are
you even in this fight it crushed me it
hurt you you felt betrayed you know like
you have to understand why you guys are
been fighting I like that one I like
that one a lot yeah I learned a lot
about that within the last few years
just because before it was just I mean I
think with a lot of people when you
argue it's a lot of ego you know yeah
yeah and you're really gonna lay that
down and realize like you said it's you
know you guys trying to solve the
problem and not just you trying to
protect yourself from being attacked you
know we had a thing called peer out
the kids at my high school where we had
learned I statements and also there was
the thing called the Four Horsemen of
the Apocalypse have you heard that it's
like the four strategies that people use
to take down each other and I can't
remember all of them but like definitely
blame was one of them and yeah
yeah Google that criticism yes okay so
back to like a lighter subject which I
found this very interesting Jasmine Kang
had two questions for us which I thought
were very interesting was should I feel
okay with my man going to a strip club
also should I feel saddened and hurt
when my man masturbates when I'm not
around
oh poor Jasmine yeah okay that's
something going on there that sounds
like she's not getting enough validation
from the relationship or from herself
you feel confident right why I'm going
to the strip club all the time well we
don't have enough details yeah we don't
know exactly like how often or if it's
just like you know once a quarter or if
it's like every weekend okay I'm eating
her yeah exactly she invited give us
more details guys I mean I think
basically we can say if it's all the
time then that's an issue for anyone
really and um
but personally I don't care if he goes
with his friends every once in a while
like it's a birthday or something that's
fine the whole masturbating thing it's a
natural thing that humans do and it has
nothing to hurt you and I personally
don't feel like you should be saddened
or hurt by that at all because you're
making him feel bad for something that's
so natural and you could masturbate all
the time - yeah exactly this is like
yeah this is one of those things where
we can't just be like just be cool with
a girl cuz it's like she has a moral
issue that that it's it's just really
not in line with most people's moral
standard like her moral standard is so
much higher than a lot of us and also a
lot of guys so she's gonna have a hard
time with this and that I feel like that
might be something that she needs to
talk to in therapy because it just
sounds like there's something deeper
there that doesn't let her register that
like guys have sexual needs that are
completely removed from anyone that
they're with no matter if that's their
wife and they love them and it's
though they will die for this woman
they're still gonna want to like
masturbate or maybe they'll [ __ ] want
to watch porn every once in a while or
something like it literally doesn't have
anything to do with you but there's just
it seems to me that she can't separate
that well I think as soon as it ends up
affecting the relationship is when if
there's if there's a problem that he has
right like with porn like cuz there is a
sex addiction that will affect the
relationship we don't know how far he's
going or if like he's doing this in lieu
of having sex or yeah and when it's
affecting the relationship that's very
small I feel like most relationships do
not have that problem yeah my my
personal experience I've never had a guy
choose porn or masturbation or sex or
strip clubs or anything over me so I
feel I mean so anecdotally I don't feel
like most guys have a sex addiction
[ __ ] to I also I guess personally like
I don't
masturbating doesn't bother me at all
because it's like we all have pent up
energy and like I feel like that's a
form of repression if you can't just get
it out I don't know like you should be
autonomous with your body but the strip
clubs I think would bother me and that
would be a conversation I would have
like why do you feel the need to go all
the time like what does it give you
because like there's so many places you
can go that aren't that and I feel like
I mean whatever your line in the sand is
if that's a deal-breaker for you then
definitely have that conversation
because I feel like for me it's kind of
it for me it seems immature and I think
that's what turns me off about it and I
it would be a deal-breaker for me right
okay so Steve words like hey it's my
friend's birthday bachelor party is fine
right birthday major events yeah it
seems like you should expect that right
I don't know that but if you're just
going like on the weekends to get really
nice we're like during the work day
where your friends want to chill all the
time that's yeah that's still weird but
the thing is girl you can't force him to
stop you got to just say like this is
what he likes and I'll let you know I
don't like it but then if he wants to
keep doing that you just gotta decide if
you want to be in it because if you try
to force it out of them it's yeah it's
not gonna work just draw your line in
the sand okay next question is from
auntie Fifi how do you tell your partner
it stinks down there and that's why you
don't go down there anymore it is a girl
a guy it's a it's a girl no guy sings oh
the guy depending on who she you know oh
yeah you don't know if she's with the
girl right babe so how do you tell your
partner that stinks down there I just
gently just like hey so I just want to
talk about something maybe like we do a
lot of dicks Mel I guess some don't know
how to take care of their dicks balls no
Oh balls can smell steve is extremely
hygienic he that's why he doesn't like
morning sex because he feels like he
wants to like be clean down there before
just put it in and kind of like do the
spoon he needs that as foreplay before
every time yeah you always have to suck
his dick he can't just put it in a
strike against Steve finally like I mean
I don't mind it like it's like part of
our sex you know in high school I had
true boyfriend he was yeah Wow knocked
you back a lil stinky know what this
dude he was like he was like the first
guy that I was seeing more regularly and
cuz like my sexual experiences before
this guy it wasn't like it wasn't like a
relationship or anything it was just
kind of like oh we're hooking up and
then that's it and it wasn't like a
continuous thing so I I just felt by the
time we got into something that some
guys just smell and I just had to just
put up
with it was he uncircumcised wasn't no
way he had skin
oh and honestly I've been with a lot of
uncircumcised guys and most of them take
really good care of their dick so I
don't want to put that I don't want to
put that stigma yeah yeah I don't want
to do that either because he's get ya
know he's perfectly that once and but
yeah but this dude though every time and
I'm like I didn't know how to tell him
either cuz I was so young and I just it
was embarrassing he was older so I'm
like I don't know is this a normal thing
like guys Magma jeez ya dick cheese
times - thank you that can be eesti and
then that can cause it you can think of
you I think something but like I don't
know being with him I'm like this can't
be it like it depends on how close I
think you are with that person like are
you just kind of boning this person
every once in a while and you're not
close enough to like really give him
that heart advice but still if I was
just boning something and that was the
only thing I was getting yeah this was
in too deep TIFF - never yeah like I
would literally don't eat that I think
at this point I mean honestly just be
honest but don't be a dick and be like
dude you [ __ ] smell yeah hey do you
mind if like we should oh yeah do you
mind if we shower you can start out and
then like just try to Jack them off with
a soap honestly I mean you have to
basically say something eventually
unless you don't want to not yes you
don't have not be honest oh yeah and one
thing that hides all that so you don't
even know is your clothes and style
cover up all the spill stitch fix
actually is getting dressed in the
morning
all right so stitch fix I love it
because we all wish we had a personal
stylist but it's how
expensive but with stitch fix you get to
go on and kind of like basically have
your own personal stylist without the
enormous fee you go on there you take a
quiz you tell them what pictures you
like what pictures you don't like and
from that they get a sense of your style
and they put together a box for you with
a mixture of clothing and accessories
and it's got all kinds of styles budget
or styles and stuff for your budget you
pay a $20 styling fee for each fix which
was credited towards anything you keep
you can schedule it at any time there's
no subscription required plus shipping
returns and exchanges are easy and free
and stitch fix does the hard work for
you it makes great style effortless for
everybody including women men and kids I
actually love this pair of jeans that I
got from them and earlier we were doing
a podcast episode where I was wearing a
shirt the bay's that so you came in and
I'm like girl I love your shirt you're
like you got it from my stitch fix
pocket it's so cute the jeans that I had
I lost too much weight so they're not
really fit me I don't know I don't
remember I was a lot chunkier when we
first did when we first got the stitch
fix box your version of chunky is like
everyone's go away I'm like really
skinny now so I need needs to be likes
to you get started today at stitch fix
calm / a mood and you'll get 25% off
when you keep everything in your fix
that stitch fixed calm / mood for 25%
off when you keep everything in your fix
stitch six stitch fix calm / mood oh
thank you so back to it okay so what if
say your cat say I'm the one with the
stinky place yeah what if I had a Ricky
stinky think you'd be able to tell oh
girl I want for sure what I want someone
to tell me but if he's like down there
it's been a long day let's say and then
it smells or whatever if he pulls out
his phone goes to goes to a smelly cat
damn friends references damage
personally so you know like you kind of
go through the month and sometimes you
smell and taste a little bit different
um you taste yourself well I mean I
don't know what I did my self we're not
throwing like I don't know like this day
I'm bitter this D says I'm always sweet
like a delicacy whatever Filipino
delicacy likes trout melted strawberry
ice cream Oh with the melted can like
you know he's like peaches and honey
which thank God but I learned that I
taste differently when I'm ovulating and
when I'm not yeah like right before my
eating your ovulation juice bro damn
right they are and they're gonna like it
but if it tastes a little bit different
like all he just has to say is oh um I
like well I would literally say and then
or more he'll be like oh no it just
tastes a little bit different today I'm
like oh okay that's cool like because I
kind of understand my body
yeah because some girls especially young
girls because I didn't know like when I
first had a bacterial infection those
are the ones that smell bad you know if
you get a yeast infection it usually has
no smell at all it's just like
discharged but if you have a bacterial
infection it will smell bad and some
girls seemed art seem to think like that
that's natural but it's not so like
they'll just run with the bacterial
infection for months or young because I
had no idea yeah so like I like fishy
kind of yeah so the very first time I
got a bacterial infection it was fishy
and I was like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with my [ __ ] you know cuz I could smell
it I have a very sensitive nose but then
I've smelled it on other girls too like
girlfriends in high school and stuff and
I'm like oh she's got something going on
and then like weeks later I'm like oh
she's still going on to the bathroom
together yeah and like it's like maybe
like a cheer and cheer or whatever like
we get really close to each other and so
I could smell her [ __ ] vagina and I'm
like so I don't think she knows to treat
it and it's
it's been weeks and it still smells bad
it's like how do you tell someone I mean
as a girlfriend I don't think we need to
do that but like if you're a guy and
it's your girlfriend's never smell me
and I smell better tell me as a woman
how would you want your man to tell you
like hey I don't know just yeah thinking
of that it's like I don't know if he was
just like hey are you on your period or
something cuz it's something did you eat
did you eat asparagus you know what for
me I think because you have to be honest
cuz like a girl might have a bacterial
infection or not know and that she can
actually [ __ ] you up those questions
came at me I'd feel more hurt it was if
but if it was like if it was like like
fluffed up in the beginning where it's
like baby I love you so much
you know I do and I don't but what if
you don't love them yet okay well or
like I really like you I care about you
I'm pretty here about you and I'm not
telling you this to to hurt you at all
I'm telling you this because I care
about you it's just that you know I've
kind of noticed that there's been like
it's like like odor and maybe you would
want to get that down too but if it was
like like prepped where it's a yeah hey
I'm trying to let you know this because
I care about you and I'm not trying to
hurt you that I would receive very well
right in way as you to be able to judge
the person we are they kind of a goofy
[ __ ] [ __ ] person or the [ __ ]
person and so Steve but we're really
sensitive when it comes to those things
yeah yeah I mean for me I think if a guy
was like if he was down there he goes
did you eat asparagus I would be like
[ __ ] oh oh it smells like asparagus
or something then and then then it would
be in my mind and I would be like oh
maybe I need to see what if is there
something going on like versus you if he
was like look honey this is a [ __ ]
problem and I got the aging in it
I would be so embarrassed so I think
it's it's hard you have to be older we
have read the person right yeah cuz then
that like your version that would work
for you to me yeah feels
passive-aggressive I think ultimately if
you're meant to be with that person
there it's they're gonna get over it's
gonna be fine yeah yeah but better to
tell them not as a person as a person
you should be prepared for that kind of
questions you don't let it freak you out
yeah take it as a it's a it's a
consideration that's not personal really
we all smell [ __ ] disgusting at some
point or entropica jungle humid and and
I see it as if they tell you that means
they want you to they do care they care
they want your favorite because they
want to bone you again yeah alright
we're lightening so next question I feel
like we can all relate to this and have
an answer to this Amy
Yan asks what do you miss most about not
being in the public eye miss most about
none I know being able to just not have
to put on makeup when I go out because
sometimes I'm like [ __ ] it I'm gonna
look like dog [ __ ] today and then I run
into a fan I'm like I'm sorry I'm
supporting a person the [ __ ] is I went
out for like the first time ever during
quarantine cuz um I would visit admire
parents for the first time I hadn't seen
some seen them since Christmas and they
live in Santa Barbara and they had just
opened up the downtown area and it was
very like you had to wait in big lines
to get into anywhere but like I went
into the Sephora there but I like didn't
put on any makeup I was like whatever we
all have masks on everyone's masked up
like no one can tell anything but people
recognized Steve he's big and tall and
[ __ ] Steve
very distinctive hairline so then they
we took pictures and I was like this is
the ugliest picture they just did
because I didn't want to take it off and
like maybe a more yeah yeah I know I I
always have my max mask on but I've
literally only been out just that time
and one other time when I went to Trader
Joe's and got plants I think the worst I
ever had was um I was driving home after
I went to this spa or I went to get a
facial and so on I was like blood
facials where they puncture you with
like million vampire facial worth it I
thought was dope I mean like it's not
fifteen hundred dollars pensive but I
thought was dope so I was driving home
from that and I I looked insane like oh
yeah I look like my face got peeled off
right yeah so I'm waiting for a parking
spot in my apartment and then this car
pulls up next to me and says hey your
taillights out here Gigi you know and I
was just like and look like the red
skull oh thank god now he's just gonna
go for this [ __ ] looks [ __ ] yeah how
do they recognize you oh man it was so
bad like I've run into it'sit's weird
running into fans sometimes I ran into
someone else at Planned Parenthood
trying to get a hold in birth control
and like these like teenagers came in
they're like I'm just like just I'm
trying not to get pregnant you know can
we take a picture and like in front of
the phone you know it's hired a place
man
so that that's the one thing that I miss
when I can just go out and just do
random [ __ ] without people recognizing
for me I miss and this is kind of like
like bittersweet or whatever but I kind
of miss having my life being private
because dude saying so like I've
revealed so much about myself and so
much about like my marriage in
particular cuz that's like getting
scrutinize a crazy but it's because like
I invited that that in so I understand
that it was
doing obviously cuz like right no one
else is releasing my information other
than me so that part I kind of like the
negative that comes with it is the part
that that I I guess I could use the word
regret but not really I don't regret it
because of the fact that there's so much
good that comes out of it too right and
so many people are always reaching out
saying like how much me talking about my
issues in my past and my trauma all
these things have helped like you guys
you know feel less alone so that part
makes me feel like okay it was worth it
but like moving that to the side just
looking at the negative I'm like damn I
do miss having privacy like not having
all that being put out there it's
stressful because you have to do like
announcements and like I see all those
like the couples that would break up and
they would have to do these
announcements or something I'm just like
yeah many people saw that right so I am
glad I'm not like super mega famous like
I feel like I'm still able to focus on
what I'm passionate about without
feeling pressured to do like something
that I'm yeah an actual serious level of
Fame for me I feel like and this is
gonna sound weird cuz I think for most
people it's not this way but like when
I'm introduced to new people or I'm even
as I'm dating and I like show them my
Instagram usually I'm like I don't want
to give you I just wish I had like a
normal person Instagram with like 300
you start a fake one but then it you
want and also private it has two
accounts I have yes so I have wonderful
yeah both have [ __ ] and a follower
that's true now the point is though I
just want people to treat me like a
regular person because sometimes like
I'll be on a date or something and then
I'll start revealing more and more and
they're like you have a hundred thousand
like it I start like they project on to
me this influencer right mindset I'm
like no I'm not really like that like
it's not that's not a big deal to me
like they start acting like well you
know people like me too you know I just
because I don't have a hundred thousand
I'm like I've gotten so much of it to
him like their own insecurities yeah
but it's just annoying tour where I'm
just like I'm a [ __ ] absolutely
normal person and don't like walk into a
room with me and be like oh yeah and
guess what she has on her dozen
followers she's the big superstar like
200 kind of jokes make me feel like
they're they're kind of like jabs - yeah
dude get down a notch for no reason like
I don't really care about that kind of
stuff like it's it's weird how when you
don't have that then you like project
this shitty kinda I mean there are a lot
of shitty influencers or whatever so I
put into the same umbrella yeah so
that's the thing I think that I like the
least is that we're put under the same
umbrella these other [ __ ]
I get like random people like from high
school and like people that like barely
know yeah from like old jobs I worked
out like hey do you think you could
promote my hey I haven't seen in a while
it looks like you're doing well do you
think you can like share my link on your
blog it's like I don't even you never
talked to me like you weren't nice to me
back then like why for me it's uh it's
like it's like family members that are
so far removed like from your immediate
family that you don't even know these
people exist but I don't know I don't
know where they come out of the woodwork
like hey I'm your cousin like from like
330 times removed I'm trying to be a
youtuber can you help me oh god yeah
what there's this guy that went into my
friend's stream and like this is like my
close friend that I've known for like 12
years and then it's like a guy that I
randomly kind of knew in passing back
when I was like 16 years old he went to
my friend's stream like last month or so
and then he's like hey do you remember
Gina from back then and my friends like
yeah and then he goes yeah ever since
she became a youtuber she's changed man
and then my friends like shut the [ __ ]
up no you barely knew her I would hope
that after like 12 years or so that I
would or 20 something like I would
change I would hope I [ __ ] change but
it's just like dude don't be [ __ ]
bitter I barely remember who you are and
like we barely even saw her there's
those people from high school that they
claimed to have known you like for me
I've I've had this one person
claims to have dated me and says that
had a bunch of those that he like [ __ ]
me so hard you know and it was right
before I got pregnant so maybe Isaac's
his kid up rumors yeah but I'm like I
literally have never seen you once in my
life like I know exactly who I've slept
with yeah you wish it was you yeah is lo
make up these rumors so then they could
feel important with whoever just so
happens to read that comment and then
people believe the comments that they
read so they're like really it's true
she did do there she is like this or
whatever it is and I'm like guys it's
it's it's not even true yeah dude when I
first started dating Joe and started
getting numbers like I remember on his
YouTube channel people would be
commenting like oh yeah I bang that girl
while she was in Austin blah blah blah
and I remember thinking like literally
when I moved to Austin I went out with
one guy didn't have sex with him and
then I went out with another guy and I
did have sex with him so I slept with
only one person in Austin and then Joe
came and he was the only other person I
slept with the entire time I was in
Austin and I was like this is not the
one guy slept with so why are you lying
yeah like I you know they think that
like oh I'm from Austin so everyone's
gonna believe that like oh I've just
been this girl that's been in Austin I
was the only there for a short time and
I'm like why are you lying on my is so
weird
it's like who would clean what they
slept with you but I'm just like have
you seen do you see you have you seen
any why they have to make the also here
in [ __ ] like Missouri yeah like what
have I been there just use you dusting
it's ridiculous but that is the end of
our episode thank you guys so much for
all your questions yeah we're gonna be
bangies I would love to get some like
really detailed questions though like
this is my this is my Graham yeah so
maybe we will also add like a thing
where they can email us like a little
bit of a longer question or DMS you're a
longer question wouldn't be those DS and
into the DM so we can get more info I
would love to hear your actual actual
story so we can talk about that but
we're definitely gonna do this more so
make sure you follow our instagram we're
gonna be prompting everyone to ask
questions there and also cleaning a
[ __ ] clean your [ __ ] so that no balls
meanwhile and your [ __ ] you taint and
also help us come up with a name for
this segment because this is fine I like
being able to answer you guys's
questions you know yeah help us come up
with a name and as always make sure you
guys subscribe like the video give us
five star I've started ring oh I just
remember you're 18 she was like Gina was
like what if we sat in a circle and ask
questions and we called it the mood ring
we filmed it like that's some turn to
talk oh there you go we might have all
my dog we might just do that anyways
thank you guys so much for watching
we'll see you guys next week Hey